because service is the ultimate
renewable energy source like when you're
coming from that place from the heart
where you're like I'm really here to try
to convey something that I think can be
a benefit to other people that's what
gets you through the adversity you know
that's what's gonna allow you to show up
for it day after day after day when
you're facing obstacles the more that
I'm in that service mindset of like how
am I helping people that's what not only
keeps me going but keeps me excited and
also gives me the that extra boost when
you're when you're tired and you don't
want to do it or you're faced with an
obstacle that you don't think you can
get over and I think it's the secret to
success if you can find a way to do
something that you're passionate about
and tie that to service in a meaningful
way
that's when doors fly open and that's
when the universe again shows up to
conspire to support you